How cool would it be to see a real life t rex if only that one fatal asteroid
never hit the earth?
Would dinosaurs still be alive today?
Would they have evolved?
Would humans have survived this long?
Could we ever learn to coexist?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if dinosaurs never went extinct until 66 million
years ago.
Dinosaurs of all shapes and sizes roam the earth,
intelligent,
adaptable,
and sometimes weighing as much as two jet planes.
It's hard to believe that it only took one rock to wipe them all out.
Of course,
this was no ordinary rock.
The asteroid that took out the dinosaurs was nine miles wide and hit earth with
the destructive force of 10 billion Hiroshima bombs.
The radioactive shockwave obliterated everything for hundreds of miles in every
direction and 75% of all species on earth went extinct.
If that asteroid had hit just a little earlier,
a little later,
or even a few miles off course,
we would be living in a very different world today.
The rock that killed the dinosaurs struck the shallow waters of Mexico's Yucatan
peninsula.
Had it landed a little farther off the coast in a deeper part of the ocean,
the water might have absorbed some of the blast along with its devastating
effects on the atmosphere,
but even if the asteroid missed the earth,
dinosaurs would have to survive several significant global events in order to
make it to the present day.
55 million years ago,
temperatures rose.
The climate was eight degrees hotter than it is today.
Rain forests,
sprouted and vegetation flourished.
Herbivores would have adapted and thrived,
but they'd have started to look a little different.
The plants of this period were less nutritious and easier to digest,
meaning dinosaurs would likely shrink in size since they're new diet wouldn't
have as much energy.
Roughly 20 million years after that,
South America and Antarctica Split,
creating a cooler and drier world climate.
During this period,
long legged,
fast moving dinosaurs would have evolved to travel the huge grasslands
stretching out across the globe compared to mammals have this period.
Dinosaurs held significant advantages such as having more teeth and better
eyesight.
Considering the dinosaurs were already so advanced,
scientists wonder whether mammals would have evolved at all if dinosaurs hadn't
gone extinct.
It's likely that the big animals we know today would have been prayed to
dinosaurs,
but remember,
humans evolved alongside woolly mammoths and saber tooth cats.
While those species didn't survive the ice ages of 2.6 million years ago,
given the evolutionary traits of some dinosaurs,
there's a chance they might have persistent,
but what about us could we handle freezing temperatures and huge terrifyingly
vicious predators?
They say running keeps the body warm,
but that might also make you taste better in an alternate universe.
If we did survive alongside these prehistoric beasts,
it's possible we could see a real live to you racks on a protected reserve,
not unlike Jurassic Park.
Human population growth and access of hunting would've driven larger dinosaurs
to near extinction today,
they would most certainly be an endangered species,
but those that shrank and adapted over millions of years could coexist
peacefully among us.
In fact,
some actually do.
Where do you think pigeon's came from?
It's hard to believe that birds were once the size of biplanes,
but then again,
it's hard to believe that with a slight twist of fate,
we might have walked with dinosaurs or we might've become dinosaur chow and not
have evolved at all.
But seeing is believing at what if,
so,
if you've got a passion for the incredible,
then keep watching.